okay let's talk about this
uh wonderful process of merging
okay so there's the main net
which is the ethereum 1.0 chain or the
ch
what should we say the chain that uses
proof of work as a consensus mechanism
and then there is uh what is it called
the the beacon chain
that uses the uh the the proof-of-stake
mechanism and i believe the
beacon has been deployed successfully is
is working
so that was in december 2020 there's a
bunch of questions around that that's
fascinating as well but
i think the most fascinating question is
um
it's about merging those two when do
the two chains one that's proof of work
one that's proof of stake
merge and what are the most difficult
parts of this process
right so as you've said right the way
that we have
set up this proof of stake transition is
that at first
the proof of stake chain just launches
on its own right and this is the thing
that happened
in december and the proof of stake chain
has been
running for close to six months and now
um i mean by the time people watch this
it might actually be six months
um but it isn't actually coming to
consensus on anything except for itself
right so the idea behind that is to just
give the proof of stake chain time to
mature
time for people to build the ecosystem
around it time to make sure that there
aren't any bugs
um and just like prove to the community
that no proof of stake actually is real
and it's
uh and a full transition is realistic
because you know the thing that you're
transitioning to
already exists and already works and
then at some point in the future
you have this event called the merge
where you basically
take the activity that's being done
inside of the proof of work chain
and you actually move it over into the
proof of stake chain so you get rid of
the proof of work side completely
so the way that the merge will
work is um and it's definitely gone
through a few different iterations like
the the the earlier versions of this
actually required more work for users
and more work for clients it was much
more like
oh there's this new chain there's this
old chain and then
everyone has to like migrate from the
old chain to the new chain and then at
some point we'll forget about the old
chain
the new version is designed to be
much more seamless for users right so
basically what actually happens is that
the old chain basically becomes embedded
inside the new chain
right so starting from the merge
transition block
every proof of stake chain block is
going to contain
a block of the what we consider now to
what we consider to be the ethereum
chain today but we'll call it the
execution chain
and then at the same time to create one
of these blocks you're not going to need
proof of work anymore
right so basically at the same time you
would both get rid of the proof of work
requirements for one of these blocks to
be valid
but instead you require these blocks to
be embedded inside of the proof of stake
blocks right so you basically have like
a chain inside a chain
and this is you know from an
architecture perspective it's you know
you might think it's a little bit
sub-optimal but it actually has some
nice properties it makes it
easier to kind of think about the
consensus and think about
the what we call the execution layer
like transactions and contracts kind of
separately
and upgrade them separately um and
it also just means that the upgrade
process is extremely seamless right
because
from the point of view of a client
that's following the chain you basically
have to
up update nothing right you're still
following
the same chain and follows the same
rules except instead of checking proof
of work you'll switch to
checking that these blocks are embedded
inside of blocks of the proof station
so there'll be this merge block that
will mark this transition
and over time i guess the the new chain
will contain the full record
of all the transactions that's ever
happened on the previous chain on the
old chain so like
maybe i'm asking a dumb question here
but in
in this process is the new chain going
to have
all the information of the past
transactions
the new chain is not going to hold
information from what happened on in the
ethereum chain before the merge
right so like ethereum clients of the um
that um people are going to use like
around the time of the merge and soon
after the merge
they're probably just going to sync like
and check the proof of work chain
up to the merge and then they're going
to check the proof of stake chain but at
some point in the future i think people
will just stop bothering checking the
proof of work before the merge
got it so that old history information
is not important
for the future or like if you're
operating actively on the
on the new chain that history is not
important to you
it's not impo let's see so it's not
strictly important for
um app for just like in any
like smart contract or just like
applications that run on the blockchain
it can be important to users and it can
be important for some applications
but we're basically saying that like
maintaining and serving that
is not going to be simultaneously the
responsibility of every ethereum node
if you want that information there can
be separate protocols for backing it up
and like these other protocols actually
exist right like there's something
called the graph which is doing some
history retrieval
potentially you can just take that
entire chain and stick it on bittorrent
like
there's lots of ways to like archive it
and create kind of customized search
protocols for it
so what's your sense why uh so there's a
python two in python three and it took
four
ever for people to switch what's your
sense why this merge
has been taking longer than perhaps was
expected
i think the biggest reason is just you
know we've been
underestimating the technical complexity
there's a lot of technical complexity in
making a successful proof of stake chain
actually figuring out the transition
process
there's so that's bigger than social
complexity so it's the technical
complexity you would say is the bigger
reason for the any delays than the
social complexity
i i actually think so i and i i think
we've been
very fortunate to not have too much
social complexity around the merge
so not much drama no um i think the
the biggest part of the reason is just
because we have been talking about proof
of stake in charting as being part of
the roadmap since um
almost the very beginning of the project
right like the very first proof of stake
blog post does
from january 2014 which was you know um
two months after the project started and
like maybe even a day after the
announcement
um so you know it was proof of stake was
not something that we kind of put on any
on anybody by surprise
and then when the dow fork happened and
you know the people on the edc side
split off
i think it also just happens that a lot
of the people that were not willing to
stomach the dow fork and then join the
etc side
they were the more bitcoiny types and
the more bitcoiny types do also tends to
like like proof of work more
and so like that also sort of ended up
you know sort of
like purifying the communities on both
sides i guess
so ethereum classic is not switching to
proof of stake and
you know they're happy with their setup
and
by the time that uh you know it came
through the beacon chain launching ends
and now i think the community is
this very strongly in favor of the proof
of stake switch
but let me ask the question that no
engineer wants to hear which is uh the
question of timeline
when do you think the merge will happen
do you have a sense it might happen this
year deal since it might be pushed
towards next year 2022
um or uh or even beyond
i think early 2022 was like the most
realistic
there's i think there's definitely still
like an optimistic case of it happening
this year but like
the realistic thing to count on is
definitely the um early part of a
very early part of next year is there
specific things that stand out to you
that are
like they'll make you feel good about
progress
if you see it happening mm-hmm um so the
thing that we
had last month is that we had this
online hackathon called rayonism where
basically a bunch of
the different client developers that are
going to be part of the transition
like hacks together some test nets of
the post merge ethereum chain
so these were only test nets of what
would happen after the merge they were
not test nets of the transition itself
so the thing that people are working on
now actually is the transition
um so having a
full specification of both the
transition and post transition i mean we
have specifications now but like
in a realistic way though probably needs
to have a couple of changes and have
things that continue to be ironed out
and then have a yet test net
that does both the transition and the
post transition and then
like once you have a test network then
you just have to do a lot of testing and
audit it
um and then you know do some uh runs on
not just a specialized test network but
on say an existing test network like
robson or rinkeby that ethereum people
already significantly used and if it
works then you can deploy the transition
on mainnet
you